la popularité de communauto croix depuis
1994 ce service d'auto partage avec ou
sans réservation convenait aux besoins
de patrick dion lorsque se déplaçaient à
pied à vélo ou en transports en commun
était impossible j'aimais beaucoup la
formule de pouvoir prendre une voiture
l'un porteront aussi de l'utiliser
ailleurs dans un autre quartier mais
depuis la pandémie il partage le
sentiment d'insatisfaction de plusieurs
membres
l'entreprise a connu une hausse de 30%
du nombre de ses abonnés et du taux
d'utilisation de ses services à chaque
faute du club sur l'application de
constater que c'est à dire comme dans un
espèce de trou noir où il n'y avait
jamais de voiture fait que tout abandon
depuis dix mois retrouvez nos façons d'y
aller on travaille à augmenter le parc
de véhicules pour pallier ce problème
vécu dans les villes canadiennes qu'elle
dessert
communauto a commandé 1300 nouveaux
véhicules dont 800 pour montréal les 500
autres seront répartis entre québec
toronto halifax ottawa edmonton et
calgary la pandémie la guerre est les
chaînes d'approvisionnement des
constructeurs automobiles sont perturbés
et donc les véhicules rentrent beaucoup
plus grandes banques qui on avait prévu
les gouvernements devraient intervenir
selon cette professeur pourquoi est ce
qu'un peu plus de soutien pour
l'implantation de services
avoir accès des véhicules plus
facilement on sait que quand même prenez
pénurie mais ils attendent sont longues
et ces véhicules vont quand même
desservir plus qu'une personne
patrick dion s'est finalement acheté une
voiture en avril alors qu'il n'en avait
plus depuis 17 ans le pire c'est que mon
auto avait stationné dans la rue la
majorité du temps ce qui est ni ezubi un
peu plein mais par contre quand j'en ai
vraiment besoin comme en fin de semaine
shore à l'extérieur de la ville je sais
que j'ai ma voiture les constructeurs
automobiles risque de ne pas livrer
toutes les voitures de communauto à
temps pour l'été un problème que vivent
aussi les compagnies de location de
voitures traditionnelles qui sont à
cours d'inventaire et dont les prix ont
augmenté ici valérie michael labelle
radio canada montréal